with the first pick overall Conor McDavid Jack H
this is unbelievable there's no words to describe
how I feel right now so surreal I'm so fired
up to be a devil right now I'm so happy I'm so
thankful McDavid what a spin the recovery
the Thor at some point it's just unfair the
way he slithers around he reminds
me a little bit of a little 99 he
cut and he scores a game winers Waits
Waits TS and home cter with gets to the
front great players have that great anticipation
he gets himself to that spot he so dangerous
one-on r with a goal terer no but he skates and
handles H quite M David and Pace just turn on a
dime with a skap PL sometimes I look at Hughes
and then does remind me of time for Denny skill
these guys bring skating the hockey IQ all those
superlatives comes off and for New Jersey in scor
Five Points for McDavid McDavid WS in J her across
he again number 100 for Jack Hughes what and look
at the vision make no mistake is two get the
pleases you're going to see match oh my goodness
the sublime agility the elite players like Jack
Hugh will take advantage of that daylight know
what McDavid is and now we're starting to see
what Jack Hughes is box office material it's
Superstars colliding Jack Hugh does it again honor
McDavid it's not real one of the best in the world
Feast your eyes on number 86 in red mcdavid's
back to what we're used to see fet the very
best